let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
well happy
happy
happy hump day
thanks for joining us here at let's talk
to tony michael's podcast it is
wednesday
three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern you know what the [ __ ] that
means
that means we are live on youtube
twitter and twitch
[Music]
and we are staying pissed and we are
gonna be pissed
until we fix our democracy because we
are pro-democracy here at the tony
michaels podcast that is first and
foremost
so if you don't like democracy
if you don't like it
well [ __ ] all the way off i mean or you
can listen and get schooled a little bit
on what democracy is
because we're going to talk about it
today in the [ __ ] list
in the [ __ ] list we are going to talk
about why why we have sicknesses in our
country in the [ __ ] list
i kind of explained it today on the [ __ ]
list roundup as you guys know i have a
show every weekday on twitch and twitter
it's where we surf the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends it's called the
shitless roundup where we round up all
the shitty things on the list
and today we had a lot of shitty things
to talk about one of those things
was the school shooting in michigan
another one
another one another one another one
another one it's a [ __ ] sickness that
we have
and we're going to talk about that i'm
going to play a clip from today's [ __ ]
list roundup because i don't know that i
could say it any better than what i said
it earlier today
and we also have all kinds of shitty
things going on
we find out the former guy
had coronavirus before he said he had of
course we knew this of course of course
we knew this this was the reports back
then they just weren't absolutely
confirmed now the guy is chief of staff
is confirming it in a book apparently
because you know they got to make profit
off this [ __ ]
we have
scotus seemingly going to axe ruby wade
by hearing arguments some of their
questioning these [ __ ] fascists paid
for
sponsored scotus
justices that we have
so we ain't going to talk about that in
the [ __ ] list we also are going to bring
you bonehead of the week you guys
you guys really like this bone in the
wheat thing i really like it too where
we take three people put them on the
list you guys get pulled on twitter of
who the bonehead of the week is
and one of the persons
on the list
this week
is kind of got some [ __ ] going on so me
and gabe are going to talk about that
and then introduce to you who is on the
bone end of the week and then you guys
get a chance to go over to twitter and
vote on the bonehead of the week we also
today on this episode
today right today you're listening to
the correct show right now
here live on youtube twitter twitch
we have our guest that donish guy
at that donish guy he's the guy that
gets confused with doxing everyone oh
you're doxing it's accountability and
twitter actually just changed their
rules and where we actually recorded
this interview before twitter is
starting to change their terms of
services and kind of their rules on some
of this stuff which may affect danish's
account and some of his content
so but we'll play the interview we play
trivia as well you guys have loved the
trivia so we're going to continue doing
the trivia today we play internet trivia
internet our trivia internet edition
excuse me
is what we play with donish gabe and
donish play this time i'm i'm the one
asking the questions today so stay tuned
for that later on today in the show
we're here two hours every wednesday now
every single wednesday we got the [ __ ]
list we got the talk we got the
interview we got trivia we got it all
right here on the tony michaels podcast
and as you notice we have a lot of new
stuff going on in the background if
you're watching on youtube twitter or
twitch we got christmas lights we got a
christmas tree we got all kinds of stuff
hanging on the wall it used to be blank
behind me but i'm changing it now we're
gonna do some changes here at the
podcast we're upgrading
we're getting the upgrades we upgraded
to two hours so i figured we'd upgrade
everything else
and speaking of that we need your help
all you loyal listeners i know you guys
are out there you guys are fantastic
uh we we've grown this audience and i
really do appreciate you coming back
every week listening listening listening
this has given us the ability to keep
going go to two hours do these creative
things like the bone end of the week
have an interview every single week play
the trivia game every single week these
things are awesome the [ __ ] list
everything's awesome it's fantastic we
have gabe is the executive gabe sanchez
is the executive producer now
everything's
running like a machine
but we need your help we do need some
more upgrades
it is difficult to produce a two-hour
show every single week especially when
you do an hour stream every day five
days a week as well
but i don't mind it i'd like to do more
time if i could but we need some
upgrades we need some upgrades equipment
setup some design
so if you guys uh can
50 cents a dollar two dollars three
dollars however much you want
you go to the tonymichaels.com the link
is at the very top it's the podcast
upgrade fund our budget is about
seventeen hundred and twenty dollars for
some of this equipment and stuff we went
and and thank you for everyone that's
already given to the podcast upgrade fun
that's what you see in front of me with
the lights well you can't see the lights
but the lights the microphone a brand
new microphone you see that we got all
kinds of things going on here
that are going to be upgrades for the
podcast so i do appreciate all you guys
and if and if you can't give that's okay
too keep listening keep liking keep
sharing give us a five-star rating
give us a review on whatever directory
download us on apple spotify all your
favorite directories hell just download
us on all of them that would help
and keep watching on youtube twitter and
twitch subscribe to all those channels
and keep watching the [ __ ] list roundup
speaking of the [ __ ] list roundup stay
right here because we are going to come
back
with the [ __ ] list right after this
break
[Music]
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup arden blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your pardon blanket
today for just
99.99 actual parting's not guaranteed
the tony michaels podcast wednesdays at
4 p.m eastern 3 p.m central watch live
on youtube on twitter and twitch
download on apple and spotify now here's
tony
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast
thanks for sticking with us again we
have a great show today
that danish guy is our guest we're going
to talk about lauren bobert but first we
want to do
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] list
that's right the [ __ ] list today we
talked on the [ __ ] list roundup you know
what we do a twitch show and it's
airs on twitter too every weekday noon
eastern 11 central
where we run through the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends i actually serve
twitter on that show live every single
weekday for an hour
at noon eastern 11 central
and today i talked about the the school
shooting in michigan
and i didn't think i could say it any
better than what i said it on the show
today so i cut a little clip here that i
want to play for you and then when we
come back on the other side we're going
to talk about a few other issues
because i but i think i think this
school shooting is very very very
important to pay attention to yesterday
it happened i didn't i wasn't even aware
it happened till several hours
afterwards really no one was reporting
it um even this morning there wasn't a
lot of reports some people were were
talking about it but we've been so numb
to this
we've been so numb it's so
it's just a thing that ha it's tuesday
right
it's wednesday in america
it's pathetic is what it is
but today i talked about it on the [ __ ]
list roundup so i want to play that clip
for you right now
this is the direction they want to go
i mean if if you are if you are on the
side in this country of pro-democracy
pro-liberty pro-freedom pro-rights
pro-equality
pro-equity in this country
you are you are not you are not on the
side
of pro-life think about that
think about that
that that that is that is that is the
the [ __ ] messaging
that we are up against here they're not
pro-life
they're not pro-life
jesus christ there was it it seems that
there was a handful of children killed
in a school in michigan yesterday
because another child
got their [ __ ] parents weapon of war
and went and [ __ ] murdered other kids
in a school
and we're seeing we're seeing now
that that we're we're deadened by these
mass shootings especially school
shootings
especially school shootings
they're not pro-life they're not pro
they are anti-woman
that's what they are they do not want
women to have rights they do not want
people to have rights over their own
uteruses that's why with the vaccine
they say my body my choice
it's the same thing as the let's go
brandon it's the same thing
as welfare queen it's the same thing as
the tea party meaning anti-black dude
president we don't want a black dude as
our president
every democrat
every democrat
did and does what what barack obama did
and no one yells and scream and starts
their own tea party and all this
nonsense
they were scared of the black dude
they were scared of him terrified
just like they're terrified of women
having the right over their own uterus
men do not
want
women these conservative men do not want
women
to have the rights
that men have
they do not want people
getting pregnant
having having the right to their own
uterus and the own say over their own
bodies because frankly i'm i'm i'm your
body your choice even with the vaccine i
think it's your body your choice you
have to live with the [ __ ]
consequences dummy
if you're not going to get a [ __ ] a
proven life-saving vaccine
okay sure you can
live with the consequences
just like when a person who receives an
abortion has to live with the
consequences of that abortion because to
think that there's no [ __ ]
consequences to that is ridiculous the
same way as there's consequences to us
choosing that we have weapons of war on
the streets and in the hands of children
in this country
these are all consequences of the
choices that we are making
all of them
that's what gives us liberty in this
country frankly
and a person having abortion
should start
at the conversation with liberty and
liberty of their own [ __ ] body and
liberty of their own [ __ ]
uterus and what they do and don't do
with their uterus
the craziest part about it all is some
of these issues that i'm already
speaking about we haven't got to the
countdown yet and here we are
me ranting
in the opening we're not even to the
trendy trends in the tweety tweets yet
if you are pro-democracy out there if
you claim to be pro-democracy out there
this is why elections matter this is why
your vote matters sometimes it doesn't
feel like it
sometimes if you're in a red state it
may not it may not you may think oh i
don't have an effect you absolutely have
an
effect and we have to stand against this
type of fascism we have to
we have to
this is what they want these
authoritarians who want authoritarianism
they would have loved they would have
loved
because they thought he was actually
going to do this they would have loved
for trump
just to just to
get rid of abortion just with a stroke
of a pen they would love that that's
what they want they want authoritarians
they want fast acting stuff
right they want to be able to get rid
of who they want to get rid of fast
right that's why they always that's why
they always lead
lead to this this
crazy ass [ __ ] about guns
and self-protection and the nonsense
and it's gonna continue it's gonna
continue i'm going to try to find the
tape of uh chris murphy rushing back to
the floor
of the house of representatives after he
had already left he coming back to to
the capitol going to the floor
and speaking on this issue
chris murphy
as you know is a senator from
connecticut
who
spoke out
and
had a heavy hand in some of the laws in
connecticut after the new town
shooting
which has been in the news here lately
with alex jones being able to be sued
for the defamation of those parents
claiming it's fake and they're all
actors and all this [ __ ] and there
wasn't really a shooting
and if you don't think all this stuff is
tied together
if you don't think that the problem is
that all this stuff is tied together
well then you're not paying attention
to think that that the people who want
to make sure they can mow down their
enemies with a weapon of war like kyle
rittenhouse did
and
kenosha he went there to kill black
people
stop saying otherwise
he went there to kill black people he
heard there's the black lives matter
protest
and that's why he went there
with a weapon of war
with the intent to kill and he did
and we see it we see it in the tapes
that weren't admitted in the court
where he was violent with a woman
punching her in the face over and over
and over again
we also see it in the tape where he was
claiming that he wanted to shoot people
from a distance if he had his gun he
would put rounds into them i think was
his exact words
this is what they want they want this
the pro-lifers
pro-life my [ __ ] ass
my [ __ ] ass pro-life
you know in the late 1990s when these
school shootings started to be
more prominent
after uh especially like after the
columbine incident
at the columbine high school
where those two
teenagers went into a school and killed
their classmates with weapons
the gun lobby
at that time in the late 90s
thought
that these school shootings and these
mass shootings were going to be bad for
business
that's why they kind of
uh adjust their positioning and you you
have clips of wayne lapayer
the head of the nra at the time and now
now the dis disgraced head of the nra
because they're a [ __ ] fraud and
they're and and now they become more and
more of a russian-backed chaos machine
it seems
well wayne lapierre went to congress and
testified that yes they were for gun
control they were for background checks
they were for sensible
gun laws
because they seen mass shootings as bad
for business back then
but then as more mass shootings started
to happen
especially after they lifted
the guns that were banned we've had them
banned before they've already been
banned in this country and the ban
worked
this is not something new we've done
this and it worked
but as the ban was lifted they
discovered that mass shootings and
school shootings
well that's not bad for business that's
good for business
believe you me
in michigan
today tomorrow this weekend and then
over the next few weeks gun sales will
be up
because of that shooting in michigan
and it's not because they're afraid and
they don't have enough [ __ ] guns that
ain't what it is
that's not what it is
they're terrified
that it'll take your guns away from you
well let me tell you something
let me tell you something here
and i thought about this yesterday
because i watched one tape and i read
one report on the shooting
because there wasn't many no one was
reporting it no one gave a [ __ ]
no one gave a [ __ ]
and the reason why is because uh there's
a school shooting ah well it's tuesday
in america
it's [ __ ] tuesday in america
wednesday wednesday they're going to try
to take away women's liberty tuesday we
got a a kid with a weapon of war going
into school killing other kids
yeah you know it's a tuesday in america
what what's on the menu for thursday
merca usa
usa huh what's on the [ __ ] menu
but here we sit
thinking about another
school shooting
children killing children with their
parents weapons of war
because i don't know they have to defend
themselves the parents that is from
so that that way the kid can go to
school and kill other children i don't
know i can't [ __ ] figure this [ __ ]
out
i cannot [ __ ] figure it out
in gun violence situations in this
country you are not killed by someone
you don't know
most the time you are killed by the gun
that you own
or that is in your household
did you know that oh my god statistics
are a [ __ ] aren't they facts are
just a [ __ ]
these guns are not for self-defense
they're not for self-defense
it's it's not that's not what this is
he was not defending himself
against other people he was going in
and mass murdering now why where and how
and all that kind of stuff
you pro-lifers out there shouldn't give
a [ __ ]
but you don't you're not pro-life
because you know what we're doing in
this country you know what we're doing
to these children
this next generation that's gonna not
not just the generation below us
millennials but the generation below
them think about that for a second think
about two generations below the
millennials because the millennials some
of the millennials were actually trained
in actor
active shooter training in their schools
elementary middle school high schools
they were trained
now they're all trained every one of
them
from preschool
all the way up into into college they're
trained of what to do when an active
shooter comes in but think about that
for a second
think about that for a second when these
sheriff's departments come in and they
do these active drills and they do these
active shooter drills and they do this
training not with just the teachers but
with the students as well they're
training the shooters
on what the protocols are going to be
that's where we're at in this country
that's how prevalent this problem is
is that even in our defense the best
defense we have is to make sure that
that people understand how to stay safe
when there's a [ __ ] maniac with a
goddamn weapon of war running around
their building
we're not only training the people to
make sure they stay safe are as safe as
they can stay
against the assault
of a [ __ ] weapon of war
but now we have a situation where all
over this country
we're training the active shooters
themselves
that's right
giving them exactly there's a video
and i hope someone verifies the
situation in the video the situation in
the video
and and and really um thank everything
for these cell phones these kids having
these cell phones in schools uh and and
schools should not ban cell phones they
should not ban digital devices because
without some of those digital devices
that those students and those teachers
had
it's possible that this person
or people in general
that do these type of acts
where whatever triggers them to go get a
weapon from their parents cabinet and go
to the school and shoot their classmates
whatever whatever causes that
the simple placement of these
communication devices whether it be a
cell phone or a tablet or something
mainly cell phones
that the communication is fast
and they have less minutes to put
[ __ ] deadly rounds
murdering people
children
aren't we aren't we having enough don't
we
isn't this enough
isn't it [ __ ] wasn't newtown enough
wasn't marjory stoneman douglas enough
wasn't that enough didn't we have enough
what about all the other ones
when it when when is it when is enough
going to be enough for you pro-lifers to
understand that what you're doing is not
pro-life
ah
and again if you don't think these
issues have anything to do with each
other you were [ __ ] fooling yourself
you were [ __ ] fooling yourself and
you're trying to fool everyone else
so
as we reflect
on another [ __ ] school shooting
where handfuls of children were
needlessly [ __ ] murdered
because we can't seem to understand
that it's our choice that we're making
in this country to continue this
slaughter
welcome back
thanks for tuning in to that clip
uh
i don't know that i could say it any
better than what i said it this
afternoon about the shooting about
scotus uh about abortion rights because
they're all tied together
these anti-democracy trump-humping manga
kunan cult voodoo [ __ ] is all tied
together it's all of it the evangelicals
the christian church here in america in
general they're all tied together
and it has a lot to do
the abortion [ __ ] is a ruse
it's a ruse to promote their fascist
policies
where they want weapons of war to be
able for people to be able to murder
other people
not just in schools but on but in
protest at black lives matter protest in
kenosha
everywhere they can they want political
violence they want violence in general
they want violence in general
and they don't give a [ __ ] about life
they don't care about life they don't
care about anybody they don't even care
really about their [ __ ] constituency
we have now today which we all know that
we all knew this this is just being
confirmed today by the mark meadows book
where grandpa poopy pants the cheeto
dust mobster was he was [ __ ] coveted
positive days before we we found out he
was
he was meeting with gold star families
and he debated joe biden
all all encouraging other people to be
to not have masks
when he knew he was coveted positive
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about other
people he doesn't care about you you
dumb [ __ ]
what makes you think that their policy
on guns has anything to do with you
huh what what makes you think that
what could possibly give you the idea
that their policies on abortion has
anything to do with the life of a fetus
it has nothing to do with that not a god
damn thing
they're [ __ ] fascist they want to
take away your liberty
and they want to take it away by taking
away your rights or that you have over
your uterus that you have over your body
they want to take your rights away by
intimidating you with [ __ ] weapons of
war
that's what they want
that's what they want
well us pro-democracy people should not
give it to him
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him we should not give it
to him we should not give in we should
not back down we should not be scared
we have to vote vote vote vote vote go
[ __ ] vote get engaged stay pissed off
about all these issues because
you're gonna be pissed off about this
supreme court decision after listening
after listening to the to the oral
arguments today
it's becoming clear what this what this
group of [ __ ] bought and paid for
justices want
prove me wrong
prove me wrong
so stay vigilant
don't give up on these issues
don't give up on the system democracy
will work it's slow
but the reason why they [ __ ] hate
democracy the reason why they [ __ ]
hate it they disdain democracy is
because democracy
is the best weapon against fascism
it's the best one it's the best one we
got
we don't need guns
we don't need tanks
all's we need is democracy
equality
equity
freedom rights liberty that's why they
want to take it away from you
if they take it away from you you do not
have the best weapon to fight their
fascist ways
keep that in mind stay engaged
go [ __ ] vote and i don't just mean go
to the ballot
everything leading up to the vote
i'm talking about engaging with your
candidate in your in your congressional
district at your school board all your
local elections your state elections
stay engaged find your candidate back
your candidate when the candidate when
the pro-democracy candidate that you
want doesn't win the primary support the
next pro-democracy candidate
it is more important now than ever to
support pro-democracy
candidates
non-fucking fascist
this is very important if you want these
issues if you want to continue to talk
about voting rights if you want to
continue to talk about health care for
all people to where they don't get
bankrupt and go broke
if you want to continue to talk about
education
and starting education when children are
three all the way up until they're two
years out of high school
if you want that if you want if you want
parent baby leave
so that you can be there
pro-lifers if you can be there during
the most important time of your baby's
life
vote pro democracy that's what you need
to do
stay tuned we'll be right back
you sit your ass down set the flip down
we're not finished the tony michaels
podcast we'll be right back
headline
[Music]
president joe biden delivers a 1.2
trillion dollar american infrastructure
bill that pays for roads bridges and
high-speed [ __ ] internet
brandon
[Music]
the tony michaels podcast wednesdays at
4 p.m eastern 3 p.m central watch live
on youtube on twitter and twitch
download on apple and spotify now here's
tony
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we have a great interview coming up but
before we get to the interview in the
trivia
with that bonus guy
we want to talk a little bit about
that the uh the bone heads
that we have uh we've been doing this
thing gay where we had the bone end of
the week right
everyone's really been liking the bone
end of the week don't you think
yeah i think uh
it's it's a real hit so far yeah well
and we did we did a uh we did a little a
little ditty show kind of thing like a
30 minute little thing uh last weekend
and that went really well so i think
we'll continue that i think that's a
good idea yeah it's a i think it's good
to
because i don't think everyone know
understands you know what what happened
in the in the past week
that would
uh
allow those contestants will say to be a
bonehead of the week right like what was
the back story to it and i think you
know doing the deep dive or kind of like
the breakdown of it allows everyone to
get a full context like they're not just
normally a shitty person because they
are
but this past week they did something
that was pretty shitty
and that's why they're you know in the
running for bonehead of the week that's
right that's right well i mean um
so last week
tucker carlson won hands down yeah and
this week if you go to the poll and and
the poll is on the podcast twitter
account it's at tony michael's pod
um you can go to my account or gabe's
account and you can link to it also uh
there
um but the poll is there this week let
me just pull this up here we've got don
jr
we've got chris cuomo and then we've got
bobert right
um all all
respectively boneheads for their own for
their own reasons uh but it just i i
don't i don't know uh
bobert i haven't even i just wanna i
have not even looked at the poll since
we put it out oh really okay well over
like just took off out front of course
and i think the reason why is because
some of these clips did you see the did
you you seen the um uh because we we
played it on the uh the bone end of the
week over the weekend the show
um we played the clip where sh i think
it was patriot takes right that
originally posted this video her yeah
you said in a cracker barrel i'm not
sure exactly where it was at uh yeah i
don't know it just gave me the vibes of
like a back room of a cracker barrel so
that's what i went with right okay well
you know that that works but let's let's
let's uh let me see i think i had this
where she's talking about the elevator
sir let's play that and then we'll we'll
go to the apology because we had an
apology from her too
right yeah
so uh the other night on the house floor
was not the my first jihad squad moment
uh so
i was getting into an elevator with one
of my staffers
and he and i are we're leaving the
capitol we're going back to my office
and we get an elevator and i see a
capitol police officer
running hurriedly
to the elevator i see threat all over
his face and he's reaching and i'm like
the door's shutting like i can't i can't
open it look what's happening
i look to my left and there she is
ilhan omar
and i said well
she doesn't have a backpack we should be
fine
so we only had one floor to go and i was
like uh do i say it why not i looked
over and i said oh look the jihad squad
decided to show up for work today
so that i'm not going to play the
wrestle clip but but she she said this
more than once because there was more
clips that that yeah there was a clip
that came out from september where she
was saying something similar right
omar actually uh admitted that this was
all [ __ ] she actually played a um
and i tried to download that video where
uh omar's playing a voicemail yeah
you can't you can't hear it very well
though so i didn't want but if you want
to hear it you can go find it on twitter
but you couldn't hear very well so i
didn't want to play it on show i
couldn't get the audio to to work right
because she was playing it from her cell
phone into a microphone so it wasn't
it's not that great of audio and i
couldn't find the audio um but anyways
there is
she was getting death threats but you
know
bobert actually released uh an apology
did you did you see this apology that
she released
yeah i think apology is like uh a very
nice way of putting it right right like
uh
well
should we play the apology that we found
because there's a couple different ones
out there but yeah i think this might
this might have been like
maybe like a draft version or yeah
something like that okay well let's play
this draft version as you put it and
we'll we'll talk about it on the other
side hey everyone it's me lauren i just
wanted to give you all a quick update on
the whole ilhan omar snafu um i called
her to let her know directly that i had
reflected on my previous remarks and as
a strong christian woman who values
faith deeply i only make fun of those
who are not part of my religion
and i even had one of my staff members
send a tweet saying that i was sorry for
getting caught it's like what more does
she want and now she's asking for a
public apology but like hello
twitter totally counts
jack dorsey just resigned via tweet and
he was like the inventor of twitter
and furthermore i explained to her that
i was just doing an open mic set in the
back of her local cracker barrel and
people thought it was hilarious they
were laughing and i was laughing and it
was just a joke okay
it's like
triggered much and then she hung up on
me so i think if anything she needs to
make a public apology to me and the
american people for like
not being from this like country or
whatever so in conclusion god bless
white people and god bless america
[Laughter]
that's what so apparently this dread
version maybe that's where he got the
crackle yeah i don't know
maybe maybe it was right maybe i i just
i felt like that was the that was the
vibe i was getting and if it in fact was
in the back of a cracker barrel
god damn i'm like you know you're spot
on every time right yeah no i mean i you
know
i'm just i mean that video totally
looked like a draft totally looked like
a draft yeah no it definitely was i mean
like she definitely said what she wanted
to say i mean here's the thing in both
apologies she said
uh they were non-apologies right the
videos were like hey so i called up uh
ilhan omar and i tried to apologize but
she didn't want to take it so then she
hung up on me and i think in the other
apology video she says like that's the
number one go-to for cancel culture
right like what the [ __ ] does that mean
i don't know i i can't figure out what
this cancel you know speaking of that so
she was on fox news right trying to
explain all this and the death threat
thing um after you
yeah very much double down on the i'm
the victim here right right so so i got
that clip where she's talking about
let's just go to it and we'll talk about
that yeah it was like it was drafted
before the phone call even had took
place um omar and the left don't want an
apology they want public humiliation
they want to cancel me but that's not
going to happen laura i want to say this
to you and the millions of americans who
watch this show i will not be canceled
we all know
so this is like projection too like you
don't get to choose
like you're an elected official like
they can elect you out week that the
congress can expel you they can take you
off committees i mean this is not this
is not your decision rather you're
cancelled or not your comments your
racism your bigotry your islamophobia
that's what's going to get you canceled
you [ __ ] right
but i think also like she you know she
sent after after it gets released right
you know like bravo the patriot takes
for releasing
it was just like the clips didn't stop
coming all weekend they just like kept
getting dropped and then the full one
was dropped after
but each one was just like
oh like what the [ __ ] is is going on
like she's
really surprising though to you no no no
not at all no no no i'm not surprised by
any of this i'm not surprised that this
is what she's doing i mean the the thing
that i was surprised about the most is
that she kind of said the word apology
that's the only thing she attempted
right she sent the tweet right and she
was like oh you know i tried to
apologize or whatever and you know i'm
well did you notice she sent the apology
on her official account not her personal
one did you know yes yeah yeah that this
is the same thing goes are did when
gosar um posted the
the [ __ ] anime slashing the head of
aoc and joe biden on his official
account and then he read quote tweeted
it from his from his personal account
that you know they're using their and
twitter should really fix this and we're
going to talk about twitter policy after
the interview a little bit before we go
out of the show but twitter really needs
to fix this thing where congress people
can't have their accounts suspended
because that's what they're doing
they're using this official count thing
you know in different ways of course
goes-r is using it to kind of draw cover
to the video so it stays up she's trying
to draw cover like oh it's an official
statement on my official account and
then being a [ __ ] bigot all in the
same breath on her personal account
definitely i mean it the the
the
the goal that she has to uh
well i mean that's the light lightly
yeah right right yeah
[Laughter]
but the the way that she can just in one
yeah in one breath kind of be like oh
and i apologize for you know i tried to
apologize meanwhile she's joking she's
making these jokes with a group of
people who are just a a echo chamber for
her thoughts
and her her ideologies right there and
she would never she would never
say this [ __ ] to
uh uh someone in congress in front of
their face right i don't care if it's
omar or another wiper she would never
say this kind of [ __ ] in front of
someone in there and she i mean she also
made the comments at this cracker barrel
because she thought that she was safe
right she thought she was in good
company you know she she was laughing
and they were laughing and the clan was
laughing everyone was laughing right
i mean i mean to be fair
if all these other videos of her kind of
telling the same story it's not exactly
like she didn't have it memorized but
she's telling the elevator that and oh
yeah she wants to she wants to tell her
supporters her racist bigoted supporters
she wants to tell them i'm a racist
and i call her jihad squad in front of
her face which she does not she's not
she's too afraid to do that [ __ ] i also
want to point out that i don't think any
story that lauren bobert tells is true
and i want to take it all the way back
to her i had a baby in a truck story
or the loose meat diarrhea sliders that
one's definitely true that one's
definitely true no no i'm saying i'm
saying i'm saying does how does she tell
that story oh oh oh oh yeah
oh yeah she was like they were so good
and it was a cleanse right or something
like that right exactly right yeah it's
a cleanser it was a cleansing example it
just like cleans it cleans you out you
know right um
yeah exactly yeah you're just you're on
your you're on your deathbed um
but i would say that lauren bobert has
the ability to
uh
you know again she didn't she wouldn't
say what she said if she knew that she
was being recorded and that video was
going to go on the internet i mean that
video was on cnn or msnbc i think it
made it to actual like mainstream
media
um
and
she
is i don't know if she i mean like i
know there's a petition right now but i
don't know honestly if she's going to
get the repercussions of censorship well
i i think i think the democrats are
going to move on this eventually because
um she's not she's not only not only is
she
uh
saying racist biggest bigoted things
towards another member of congress um
but she is she's inciting death threats
to another member of congress right she
continues to do it so i think but also
kevin mccarthy sitting there with us you
know
what did you expect on his hands he
didn't he didn't do anything with
marjorie taylor green or gozar still
yeah
and really honestly if they win in 2022
all you pro-democracy people out there
if they win in 2022 these [ __ ] people
are gonna be chairman of committees yeah
because trump's going to tell kevin
mccarthy or trump's going to be speaker
and he's going to appoint them
[ __ ] bet on it so here's here's our
bonehead of the week again reminder
donald trump jr chris cuomo and lauren
bobert so go vote for him
at tony michael's pod or you can go to
mine or gabe's page are the links there
to the podcast twitter also follow the
podcast
twitter while you're there while you're
voting
and we'll do another episode this
weekend
of bone end of the week uh stay tuned
because up next up next is our interview
so stay stay right there
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess
well now there's boycott binder the
ingenious organizer that keeps track of
everything and everyone you've ever
boycotted the 72 category filing system
makes it easy to organize boycotted
people places and things so you can find
them with ease the large centered area
can even fit your boycott sign but best
of all when you're done the boycott
binder folds right up so you can take it
anywhere so if you're tired of having a
cluttered mess call now and get the
boycott binder for just 29.99
plus you'll also receive our next rep as
a bonus just loop it around your neck to
travel with ease but call right now and
we'll double the offer that's two
boycott binders and two neck straps for
just 29.99
boycott binders brought to you by the
same makers of binders full of women
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
during the interview you will hear this
sound
not to worry though it just means that
we've removed some information due to
the sensitive nature of the topic thanks
and enjoy the interview
welcome back to the tony michaels
podcast we have a special guest with us
today
i don't i don't know exactly how to
introduce him other than it's that
donish guy from tick tock he is a
content creator so here he is thanks for
joining us donish i really do appreciate
this uh i i know there's a lot of stuff
that you do and a lot of things and and
i i know you originally from tick tock
and i think a lot of people know you
from tick tock uh and and the videos
that you do i think i think you would
call called it accountability tick tock
yeah a lot of people call it like
doxing and i know we'll get into a lot
of that but what i want to start out
with the question that i really want to
start with
is
because i know i s i have a tick tock
gabe has a tick tock and i started with
the whole dancing shaking your booty
videos and i know if you go down to the
bottom of gabe's because i've done it if
you go all the way to the bottom he's
got these damn so anyone out there do
not do not go to the bottom of gabe's
tic-tac whatever you do
please do not
comment thanks a lot
or or or steal them and post them on
other social media
do not do that kind of thing but there
are there are dancing videos on gabe's
in our mind so i want to know if there's
a there's a [ __ ] ton
of that guy donna yeah that donna got
that guy
videos
so
how far do i have to scroll to get to
the dancing videos how did how does your
tick tock journey it's pretty far
you go
down far enough you'll see the dancing
okay um the first the first idea i had
on tick tock was i was just gonna have a
page
where i was gonna take all these dancing
tick tocks
and anything that happens off screen i
would just be that off screen thing so
whenever their arm you know goes off
screen in the duet
you would just see my arm go up or down
oh so so so you would do the duet but
you would be yeah just the arm or the
leg or whatever or the ass whatever is
off right right um and like i thought it
was clever funny no it didn't do well at
all and the thing is like i worked
really hard on those but like no one
wants to see your [ __ ] arm donna
nobody no no
no one was interested in what was
happening off screen uh the original
creator would have included it
that's why it was [ __ ] off screen and
you know what i even named it i named it
widescreen correction because all the
tick tocks
are uh you know stand up understand
so
you're making the assumption that if
it's shot in widescreen this is actually
what this is what you were missing out
on you might be an early adopter to that
trend because that has evolved there was
that whole um
there was one
uh where was the the hostages in a house
situation i don't know if you saw the
one it was like everyone was building
around it yes i did see that when i
built so
i would say that you might be an early
adopter to that like trend you're just
too you were just too early i don't so i
don't think that's
really possible that i was an early
adapter of it because
none of the videos did well like
no one saw them
like i had the one that did the best got
i want to say 50 000 views and had 500
likes
so like it wasn't like okay
people and people so people would see it
and go
i don't like this
no
did did the algorithm like it or was it
just the people didn't like it do you
think um because there are two sides of
this thing the algorithm didn't but when
it gave me a chance
um
i disappointed them so yeah you know
cause it you know it's time to try
something different and then okay i got
away from that
so what was the next step after the the
uh
donish arms and like yeah so then i just
try to do comedy
okay again no nowhere nowhere um was not
true so it's because you're not funny or
the algorithm doesn't because i mean
there is a difference i i think people
are funny but then the algorithm may
not well i don't think it was very funny
i'm still learning the platform too so
like i was like all right this isn't
working either um i can't figure out how
to like make a good joke on here and
there's so many funny things
um
and then
and then i started to do some
uh
oh yo we actually started with
one video that i did it's no longer up
but it was just one that i was
frustrated uh the beginning of the
pandemic i was frustrated because our
state had opened back up right and so it
was a simple
like 10 second video of me just showing
some open signs and saying uh look this
ice cream shop is open this coffee shop
is open everything's open here because
we're [ __ ] stupid and that went viral
like that little like little thing there
is that's what made that danish guy no
no okay like this got me to maybe like a
thousand followers okay okay so when you
when you say viral like the video did
well but it didn't it didn't like get
you a fan base you get like the thing is
is building your account is usually a
series of like you have to have a lot of
things go viral you can't like
without just one video you got to keep
doing it and that's pretty hard so even
with that one no it didn't go anywhere
then i tried to do sketches funny
sketches uh political sketches um and
there was one that i did
that was about um
uh what was it oh it was about my son
had uh wanted to paint his nails
and
and so i said yeah okay you could do
that it's fine and
i thought to myself he was by the way
four years old three years old time i
thought to myself there's guys out there
who legitimately freak out if their son
says that to them
and i'm like he's three years old so i'm
gonna make a video saying like hey my
son asked me this and it's totally cool
i mean what's what's the big issue
and i did not expect that to go viral
but that one got like uh six million
views or yeah six million views it got
kind of it came with a heavy amount of
death threats
against my child against my
three-year-old child yeah i saved those
too because i uh because when people
wait now wait a second now wait a second
this is a video you talking about how
your son wanted to paint his nails pink
yep and and you're saying yeah that's
fine and you're you're trying to make a
point that it's okay for a boy to want
to paint his nails i literally just say
don't be your girlfriend's first bully
that's that's the message of it don't be
your child's first bullying okay i see
right but you got death threats for over
this oh yeah no people threatening to
kill my child whoa whoa whoa they were
threatening to kill the kid
i could i mean i'll i'll show you guys
the screenshots if you want to post them
if you want because um there are
usernames attached to them and i don't
mind putting it out there
because they said it people said stuff
like i would i think one of the worst
ones was someone saying they would curb
stomp my child
[Music]
there were people saying they were going
to like it was brutal a lot of brutal
things came in coming in and at that
point i was like all right i'm done with
tick tock i was going to like just get
off the whole app
but i'm pretty stubborn and that is what
really like fuels me and so i thought if
i get if i get off of this app because
of that then they've you know they're
worse they could do someone else so so
so is this is this like the moment where
you kind of had this idea like
hey maybe i can hold this person
accountable because no
okay no i didn't even look for those yet
um so at that point um i just
i thought to myself well i suddenly got
like 30 000 lgbtq uh followers like it
was that whole community lgbtqia
community was
uh loved the video so i got a bunch of
those followers a bunch of followers
from that community the one the one with
your kid painting yeah yeah okay and
because there was a lot of people in the
comment section besides the people
threatening me a lot of people in the
comment section saying when i was a
child and i tried to do this
my father uh beat me or my father did
this or this happened that and there's
just like thousands thousands of stories
i did not expect this outcome thousands
of stories that people have like being
feel like uh have to experience like
abuse or whatever because of this exact
scenario and i really like i did not
estimate this
when i first thought of like oh
most parents would freak out about this
i didn't think it was that bad
um and so it was it was actually hard on
from that aspect too because all these
people are like thank you for making
this video right and um
and then i felt okay well then i should
respond to some of the people saying
shitty things and defend
all these people who feel like um you
know who felt vindicated from my video
so uh then i started doing that and
pushing back on those people the people
who would threaten people who would say
that's wrong i kept pushing back on that
and um
that's for for for a long time after
that that remained the kind of theme of
my
profile even when i got to
political tick-tock and that was like a
little bit after that
that naturally went into politics
because because you're you're hanging on
the political side of tick tock when
you're talking about some of those
social issues i mean i
i'm making
the thing is i make a point to say that
what i do is not political right but it
ends up getting politicized so it it
ends up political even when i don't like
i i say very clearly this is not
political what you're doing here is
wrong whether it's like a racist a groom
or abuser or a pedo whatever it might be
it just
there's a certain group that tends to
identify with it and get frustrated well
and that's and that's and that's because
it's a fascist right-wing thing to
rights you know have all these
homophobic tropes these transphobic
tropes these i mean just just
anti-anything really yeah and i try to
make my link tree like educational so i
have like different like
studies uh videos and stuff on what is
um feminism what is socialism what is uh
marxism what is this just so people
understand because it's so frustrating
to have these circular arguments
um you
how can people find your link screen now
that you yeah oh
it's in the profile of all my uh
all of my uh social medias you'll see in
my mind and on social media you're the
same handle across the board same thing
yeah
okay um so uh so in that it has the last
one says just defines what marxism is
just for people who don't understand it
because i feel like a lot of people
don't know the difference between
marxism communism socialism they just
group all again they just they just say
they they say they say all kinds of
words that they have no idea they just
sound scary right right and so to to to
combat me
a lot of people um classify me as a
marxist doctor like i've never even
identified as a marxist ever i you know
what i would do
i would make some art and put that on a
[ __ ] t-shirt
marx's boxer
but i i would i would put it on a shirt
and wear the [ __ ] shirt
it's all yours
because but the thing is is that those
two phrases together uh manufactures
rage right it does what like it it's put
together for a reason they say marx's
doctor so you think oh i should kill
this person like to a right-wing fascist
like they would immediately go oh that's
okay to kill that person so right you
know what i mean so so is it the marxist
part of the doctor part that really
it does do you could replace it with
literally anything i mean it's they're
just buzzwords right it's just buzzwords
that enrage them well i mean it's kind
of you know the same the same thing as
the let's go brandon right because they
don't want to say [ __ ] joe biden right
right so so they want to they want to
use code words to say well it's so it's
okay to want death upon this person this
human this other human being because of
these words and you know well i for
instance we did
we did a bonehead of the week on sunday
right did you see the comment on twitter
gabe it said something like i don't
watch communist programming or something
like that
i was like oh my god this is perfect i i
want to now i want to now
make uh you know we have this uh really
news now this this fake news network
that we've been doing maybe we should
make it into like a commie uh akami
comrade uh communications something i
don't know i don't know you know i i i
think i i think um the the more we
deaden their words the better it is it's
kind of like
well the word doxing for instance right
yeah i know gabe you had a couple
questions on it but
tell us what you think doxxing is and
tell tell us about dachshund because i
think people get it so when uh let's
first let's uh define it the way people
who
hate accountability define it as when
they say doxxing what they hear is uh or
doxor there is someone going around
ruining innocent people's lives people
are just trying to enjoy their nuclear
families
make their extremely sexistic racist
jokes it's just a joke right and we're
not ruining their own lives here right
and a joke that we all apparently make
um and then this person comes along and
puts all their private information on
there uh
goes after their children
um tries to you know
get get them get their house taken away
their job taken away they just think of
a person coming in violating their
rights and their what is theirs and
taking it all away that's all they see
this they do not even think about that
accountability part of it at all or the
fact that it's deserved or that they did
it
um
so what doxing actually is the literal
definition of it
is does not actually meet a legal
definition of it so
it is correct to say
that like any little bit of information
anyone any literally anyone puts about
you online could be doxing but then
there's no
there's no end to like how to define
that
because anything literally anything you
could say about that person
could be considered doxing but doxing in
itself that that word
doesn't mean the legal definition which
people confuse it with and go well you
committed a crime by saying my name
no i did not
um you like you did a video about this
recently yeah well that's why robin
robbing a bank
yes i did that's what becomes so
confusing about it where i go like stop
using the word boxing because you're
trying to say i've committed a crime
like cyber stalking or harassing or
something like that
but you've defined it as like a simple
way to like that they've used to explain
like uh
just saying someone's name literally as
simple as saying someone's name
and um
the actual legal definition uh the
federal law that that um
protects people against getting docs
protects politicians protects uh if you
look at the actual law and i have looked
at it before honestly
it protects politicians and so you can't
put their information out there and even
more so than that it refers to pii and
that is very specific to
like
i can't put your password out there that
would be illegal
i can so in other words in other words
if you found the password somehow
i can't what's your problem the password
no matter how i found it okay i can't
put your password out there i can't put
your credit card number out there i
can't put your social security number
out there these things are illegal so
that's the the peii is that what you
call yes so what does that stand for
there's some identifying information or
okay private identifying information
um but uh that is those are things that
are that i would have to go through a
legal means to get
or you know it would just be illegal to
put online that is doxxing right so
you're talking again you're talking like
social security driver's license number
right um things like that yeah yeah yeah
i i don't know if driver license ever i
think so um passport like if i posted
your passport um
but i could like putting your address
out there is not boxing
and the thing is is that sucks i don't
do that i don't put out anybody's
address that is very violating um
but like that is that is not you
wouldn't be protected
right a politician would be
but you wouldn't be
so what you're saying is is like um
you're not going to put out someone's
address because obviously a lot of crazy
[ __ ] can happen if you because you could
understand
what you're saying is is the way you
understand the law of course you're not
i'm not a lawyer are you you're not a
lawyer i have no i have a lot of lawyers
that are in my dm's but right but the
but the way you understand the law is
that
uh you can
it's not considered the legal definition
of doxing to put someone's address out
there unless they're like a public
official like that that's what the law
says right there's no federal law
protecting you against toxin and this is
this is like
and this goes back to how merrick
garland and the fbi was
releasing inquiries on these domestic
terrorists who were going to school
board meetings because they started to
threaten with physical violence they
started to show up at their homes and
these are elected officials like school
board members on in most of the states
and most of the counties and school
districts in the country are elected
officials and that's why that's why mary
and that that kind of got lost in that
[ __ ] conversation because ted cruz
and josh hawley and tom cotton you know
made it about oh parents are just
worried about kids education and frankly
the people that were showing up at these
meetings were the ones who don't give a
[ __ ] about their kids education they
wanted something to [ __ ] about right
so um yeah correct um but um if i were
to make a video
and for no reason at all maliciously for
no reason at all i mean you haven't done
anything wrong it's not an attempt to
hold you accountable but you let's just
say i don't like you and i make a video
telling myself thanks a lot well
hey tell my followers here's his name
here's his address go hurt him
that's illegal yeah that is very illegal
but you're falling into other things
like sitting uh sitting a hit like
soliciting a crime still sitting um
so is that is that why that's illegal is
it not necessarily the information it's
what you're what your intention is with
it would fall that that would help it
fall under harassment cyber stalking or
other things that are actual laws but
there's nothing that'll you're not going
to get me like in court and say this guy
doxxed me like well what what happened
exactly get more detail and then you
figure out oh okay right right this guy
told people to go hurt you uh and then
you got hurt as a result right so that's
not really doxing though right in the
court that's not right it will like
again it's a different it's a totally
different crime
it's releasing information
for that the end rea there is an action
on you right and one that is malicious
or right but it's not hiring
what you're saying though is that the
the actual releasing of the address
isn't the illegal thing it's when you're
like go to this address and do this
thing
and and that applies to even like i've
seen some criticisms that say um well
donna you say don't do it
like don't hurt anyone or anything like
that but that's just like saying don't
push the red button right
and the thing is is i actually again
don't give out that address i don't give
out the address because i don't even
want it to imply anything like that but
i am very clear no we don't know
violence even in my comment section if
someone goes i'm going to hurt this
person i go you are not going to be
violent with anybody um
but um but beyond that
i'm not i'm not having anybody go do
that i'm not even going like you know
what to do
there's nothing like that you made a
video about that recently too didn't you
you know oh yeah yeah somebody did do
that they said you don't you know what
to do start sharing this video and i was
like don't leave it open ended like that
you could you could be open for like the
thing is that's irresponsible
that's very irresponsible i made a video
back but it was very clear what i wanted
to do was to get him off the platform um
and i said that too uh within that out
thank you
yeah and i i watched the
um
that tick tock um
specifically
and i believe
that um
he was he was responding to something
else that someone else responded to him
or something i i don't know i don't
remember exactly what his point was but
uh but
you put a quick stop to him about you
know don't don't be so goddamn vague you
know you know say specifically what the
hell you mean
yes don't leave this stuff open in it
because these people on the internet you
don't know who these crazies are well
you know
in his comment section there were
literal death threats
to towards his target and he was liking
those comments it was it was a [ __ ]
issue yeah it was a much bigger issue
than that too he was actively encouraged
so that that and that's the thing again
he was doing that to her because she
she's another account this is our
exorcist another account that does the
same thing i do we just hold people
accountable and so a lot of people will
do this where they will try to commit
the very crime they're accusing us of
doing right yeah and they will say
go do it to them because they do to
everyone else but we don't do it there's
there's no one that happens to sure
there will be every now and then
somebody who let's say like hiles hitler
at me or something on in a video and
i'll say hey um
that's bad
and then she gets bombarded by people
because i you know because my following
will go and say uh what are you doing
why are you doing that whatever right
um and she might uh
and and in that she might get people who
are uh
being you know uh
aggressive and stuff like that but
nobody is
nobody is hurting her nobody's going to
hurt her
and i'm not encouraging anything like
that at all
but then the thing is is they'll see
that this person gets harassed or they
get their job taken away for example
that's not what this happened to this
person but
something might happen to them
and they will go that is because of
donis actions i go i literally for
specifically that video i literally just
showed the video i actually didn't even
say do anything at all i showed your
video where you hitler and i said what
is this like i was like did you just do
this
and then there was so she posted a video
you repost it and and it spreads to more
people and she's mad that it got
distributed to more people she's mad
that people are upset i'm [ __ ] out of
here
she's mad that people are holding her
accountable she even goes for the [ __ ]
she posted yeah she goes you you um you
edited my videos like i actually showed
your entire video there was just
halfway through i stopped to make some
commentary
and then i just showed the rest of the
video i got your tic tac here which
which one is that it has about three
million views on it if you go down
um
it's it's a blonde lady um
eileen hitler
um
yeah well i i got the one that we were
just talking about let's play that one
real quick
touch me without consent and see what
happens just the most
horrible type of human being in the
world
to want to destroy this guy's life calm
down don't be so emotional jeez
you're upset about what this cancel
culture [ __ ] has got to go it's i'm
sorry is this you good men
talk to men
about being better men they hold them
accountable they don't talk to other
women super weird rule but hey why
aren't you holding the guy in the
original video accountable why are you
talking to the woman
so you played the video of the guy
joking about assaulting a woman at work
then you played the video where she
showed how she found him but you left
out where she explains all the other
tasteless things he's done in uniform at
work that circle around assaulting women
why'd you leave that video out you know
i hate accounts like yours because this
is manufacturing rage you are rage
farming that's what you're doing that's
what your entire page is rage farming
against women really
but this
this especially with this quote at the
end guys
i think we know what to do share this
share this if you
are sick of this
what do you mean you know what to do
of course like i haven't i haven't seen
a more obvious portrayal of rage farming
of manufacturing rage and sending it out
to harass someone that that is [ __ ] up
and you can say all you want that your
page isn't sexist your page is not toxic
but what you did right there what you
did right there is toxic as [ __ ] how
about this hey to my followers i have
literally never said anything like this
before but i'll do it for you because
you said men should hold other band
accountable hey to my followers share
this video you guys know what to do
we'll see what that means that [ __ ]
guy let me tell you yeah
the it kind of escalates from there
actually um
uh he's got this so that guy on this
page his wife has died two and a half
years ago and it's in his it's pinned to
his page like he loves or he misses her
and then he left her a kid
and immediately weaponizes that and says
that danish told my his followers
to come and um
uh make fun of my dead wife
which is so uh out of character but
what's actually really funny about that
wait wait from the video that we just
watched that's what he took from them
what's really fun about that is he
immediately and i guess he does he
immediately made a video
where some profile no profile picture um
had said something about his wife his
late wife and he made a video saying wow
i can't believe how horrible people are
and i commented literally seconds after
the video went up saying hey i do not
support
comments like that that is disgusting
while i have a problem with you i do not
support any attacks on uh your dead wife
so are you like wife so i i nobody do
that if you're following mine do not do
that but he had already like he
immediately had blocked me from
um my video and never saw that comment
so he didn't know that i actually had a
comment out there that said that under
his video so when i saw that he said i
was telling people threaten his wife i
was like you can't see this comment you
[ __ ] but i actually told him not
to you liar and i held that against him
and then i naturally just started
looking into him and that's when
that's when it got uh that's when it
started to get ugly um dude my video
that i put out dude follows miners um he
used to have his like videos open it was
all just minors dancing
um and i was like with someone was like
a kid at home now
that's that's scary
uh immediately report uh oh and people
were saying that he was also um
making uh thirst trap videos and
tagging these accounts stuff
so i immediately
reported for child exploitation or uh
what was it for uh
exhibition uh child exhibition or
something the laws um
but then it started to get weird because
i was looking at it with a couple
friends
and
it just it just didn't make sense his
body language with the baby in that
video that he has the fact that i like
we found him but we find no evidence of
this late wife ever existing but we
can't say that
because that's messed up
right but then we keep digging and we go
no she doesn't exist
because uh
the same video he had up or he's holding
the baby
we found it on his facebook on his mom's
facebook that very same picture and
under she commented his name is brian
brian you should have your own one day
and brian commented i don't think that's
happening
wait a second so we so so you think no i
know
you know okay so he was lying he doesn't
have it he doesn't have a wife she's not
dead she didn't exist he he made the
whole thing up made the whole thing up
so you think he's meant to be so i think
he's manufacturing this just for tic tac
he's doing this for to gain sympathy to
get people off of his back to get uh
yeah to get uh women to symbolize them
but also when there's altercation like
theirs with me oh they're making fun of
my dead wife oh so this is this is like
an armor kind of thing yeah yeah we
found out who's uh so we found out who
uh sorry savannah found out whose kid
that was
and sent the video to the parents
and said just so you know he's using
your uh kid for this to do whatever
and literally immediately after he took
down that video of his wife and his kid
and he took down any reference to that
he had a video up saying um
that you know uh you have to stop being
so
he's saying to feminists you got to stop
being so
mean to men i have there's two
firefighters i've worked with in the
last year that killed themselves because
of how women treat them well i checked
his government salaries he hasn't been a
firefighter since like 2018 he's a liar
i put that in his comments he
immediately takes that video down so
it's
all just a fraud and then he starts
saying he said today he's gonna have
evidence that is this kid
time's up buddy so
let me ask you because um
you know i i i als i saw was the one
video right yeah obviously you have
done a lot more digging of what this
actually is and the story behind this
but
it is amazing to me that there are
people that go on like tick tock
and they think that by putting videos in
themselves putting their names
putting this stuff out there that they
can stay
anonymous not just not just from
strangers
but also their family like
i have said some crazy [ __ ] yeah on
youtube i said some crazy [ __ ] on tick
tock and my family is full of [ __ ]
trump bumpers
full of them
and they probably hate my [ __ ] guts
for the [ __ ] that i've said but i don't
say it thinking oh well my family will
never hear this right like you have
surely you have to know if you're using
your whatever like a niche or net i'm
i'm just using an example i don't know
what what he you know exactly who he was
if he was using it
right so so if you're using a niece or
nephew in a situation like this to try
to gain sympathy or something whatever
the story is that you're manufacturing
you don't think your family's gonna find
out about that just not only that you
it's the fact it's like you know it this
is this is
during the age of well you know the
internet right so like anyone's
what the [ __ ] is the internet oh let me
tell you we're gonna have this dial-up
modem uh
but it's it's the fact like thinking
that you can get away with
some some lie right especially when you
have
some photograph or video or whatever
someone
is gonna is gonna do some digging right
just like you do and you're gonna be
able to find out and connect the dots
because here's the thing unless this
person is like
an incredibly well-crafted you know
sociopath and is able to line manipulate
to get what they want
you know and is able to cover all their
tracks someone's gonna trip up and make
a mistake right and that's that's it's
what you are able to exploit in terms of
finding out what exactly
the truth is
uh which is which is you know very
impressive and so i the one thing there
is like if anyone thinks that they can
get away from anyone on the internet
like anyone right it they they are
living
uh in an alternate reality where they
think that by posting a photo or video
or whatever
that they can lie about it and think
no one's ever going to figure this one
out right you know and it only takes
like one like on a different profile or
account or whatever that's it to find a
connection
so wait a second so what you're saying
is is that like if you're on a social
media platform and you have your account
you're trying to
remain anonymous for whatever stupid
reason that you have rather you're
you're making videos the best ones are
with they had their [ __ ] work name
badge on like what the [ __ ] oh my god
you are a [ __ ] idiot and they still
call it doxing when you show that right
they're they're publishing their [ __ ]
information on the video that you're
it's like one guy who showed up to the
insurrection with his work badge
other than the fact that all those
people who showed up were then posting
on their own personal profiles you know
like what no why why is the fbi at my
house right i don't know why did you
post it to your own personal account
yeah well that's like that [ __ ] jenna
ryan
barbie from yeah she's like she's like
oh we're on the private plane going to
overthrow the government of the united
states and then she's she's standing in
front of the broken window and posting
that [ __ ] on social media like oh look
and then tweeting about it and then the
judge is like maybe you shouldn't tweet
about this stuff uh you know what pisses
me off about that case really honestly
is the judge knew everything in that
case
he knew she knew what she was doing and
then he knew that she was saying the
[ __ ] like oh i'm not going to jail i'm
white i'm blonde i got black eyes i got
a [ __ ] job i'm rich whatever the [ __ ]
she was saying whatever dumbass [ __ ] she
was saying yeah
he should have threw the [ __ ] book at
her and i actually believe
that the reason why some of these judges
are starting to throw the book at the
son of a [ __ ] is because of that
and
do you find that to be the case like
sometimes like when it crosses over the
line right because you said there's a
legal definition of doxing there's the
dictionary definition right yeah just
the everyday definition but when it
crosses that line where you're like oh
my god this is
this is not just me finding someone
being a fraud like they're lying about a
wife which is not that's not a crime to
lie that you have a dead wife it's
really [ __ ] dumb and it makes you
look like a fraud
but
there's no quote-unquote crime in doing
that the thing is is that when you start
pulling the string
it's not just one lie it's not just one
thing and i'm i'm going to tell you this
because by the time this is not going to
post today right
no no i could tell you this when it
comes out you're going to know more
information um
so it's not just that as you pull the
string you find out that there are more
and more things he lies about and
and he's the type of person
who does this in his life
and um what we found out is what's nice
about having an account by the way
um at the size that i have now is when i
make a video and i post it to all my
platforms it takes like maybe five to
ten minutes to for someone who knows the
person
to contact me
and because i made a video and then you
know savannah made a video and all these
other creators made a video
it got a wider reach
[Music]
the dude definitely doesn't have a dead
wife definitely doesn't have a son uh
that is a 100 lie um you have these uh
so you have people you have people who
are in personal contact with this person
who are contacting saying confirming the
information that you have already found
and confirmed
and word and you find out worse and
they're in um they're they mostly went
into savannah's uh uh
inbox because she was the one who was um
originally
going back and forth right yeah yeah and
she found a ton of stuff and one of it
was that
um
wait wait who who is savannah first our
exorcist she was the target of this
guy's sprite brian carlson brettstarz06
she's the one in the video she's the one
in the yeah where she's like don't come
don't come in
okay yeah okay
and then she said and he sent people
after her thousands and thousands of
people after her to harass her
and try to get her platform removed
which never goes well i never understand
why if you're going to go after any
creators on this app and you have a lot
of things to hide why go after the ones
that have branded themselves as people
who find out [ __ ] about your personal
life like why would you do that
you're asking for trouble and and today
like take both of us he was telling me
following his base let's take out danish
and her and i'm like are you kidding me
so here's so here's their solution right
now i want to stop boxing so my solution
is to go get doxxed as they consider it
by accountability tic-tac what a bunch
of [ __ ] rights
horrible horrible things we also by this
time
that that is and that is really the
logic to all of this and i take it and i
blame donald trump for this because it
goes back to
um don't worry about the content of what
you found it's the leaks who leaked it
the leakers are the problem and that's
wait wait see so you're saying you're
saying these people that's their mindset
is that is that it's not it's not really
the the criminality or maybe no the
fraud or
or the racist toxic kind of years right
no it you know what it is whoever smelt
it
that's what it is
[Music]
i was wondering i was wondering what
that stench was gabe
so speaking speaking of real [ __ ] big
boneheads who just won't quit who just
won't stop but you cannot who cannot
[ __ ] seem to get a [ __ ] clue when
you're talking about uh someone
targeting
big creators now i i don't know every
detail of this backstory but i did
notice it on tick tock and i did notice
it on twitter but there is this account
this [ __ ] bonehead um and any
unfortunately he has a beard he wears
hats he can he get
you know you know you know you know what
i'm saying yeah yeah i broke it as a
program right right
the
i cannot i cannot figure out why someone
thinks it's a good idea for for their
clout right because
uh tick tock has
separate pens right there's like the
liberal tick-tock political uh there's
the trump humping side
tick tock right there's the dancers
there's the trends there's the there's
like makeup you know they're crazy right
there's all kinds of crazy ass crazy ass
stuff on tick tock and they're all kind
of
again
i don't want to use the word segregated
because uh of the you know the stuff
around that word but uh
i guess that's maybe the only word other
than it's penned up in separate pens
because you don't really i mean you have
a little bit of crossover on tik-tok but
not a lot as far as i'm con you know
like when i'm on there
so why why anyone
would go on tick-tock and like you know
what i want to do i want to build my
following on my side of tick tock so
what i think i'll do is i'll go on a
totally other side of tick tock
and i will i will throw [ __ ] flames i
will throw garbage into this thing i
will not only do that i will go after
the biggest creators and
[ __ ] call them all kinds of names and
make sure i get their attention and make
sure they respond to me
and when i do that when i do that i will
play the victim and i will win all kinds
of clout on the other side which i don't
understand because that's not exactly
how it would work but you know the guy
that i'm talking about i think i believe
his first account of course he said like
four or five i think his first account
was called misfit patriot correct me if
i'm wrong yes mystery patriot
and i think you uh i think
you have uh called him out uh i don't i
think it was lance um
originally yes originally
because because he was going after lance
was kind of the the thing right yeah
yeah right and he was he was making
accusations which you know it doesn't
matter what the accusations were he was
uh making accusations that lance was a
criminal is what he was doing right
without any evidence yeah right but it
wasn't even like based on anything he
just kind of just says it right right
i just feel this way right right
well i mean yeah right well so profiling
yeah
you know
you feel that way about a lot of things
i'm sure misfit page
you know
it did it did start with
lance and they had a little back and
forth and then one day he just had like
he woke up with just the biggest balls
in the world and he decided i'm going to
ask
all the creators of millions of
followers lance tisiant and aunt karen
to
delete everything oh because he was
going to send them a cease and desist oh
yes i seen this video what a like
like this i think this is what really
blew it up because
he was so serious
so confident that a a cease and desist
was like a magic lamp that could just do
anything like he was so unclear on what
a cease and desist is it literally as
you pay an attorney they write a letter
it is it's an expensive it's an
expensive way to say please stop was it
it was it was 3 750 i think if i
remember the video correct you show the
receipt right yeah
he paid 3700 for someone to write a
letter because someone was making tick
tocks that he went over there and told
them to make tick tocks basically
because i mean let's let's let's let's
back up here because the reason why he's
so [ __ ] pissed here's why he's pissed
is because
he gets mad when lance says colonizer
because he is one yeah he gets pissed
off because he's a [ __ ] racist he
knows he's a [ __ ] racist
and he gets pissed off when lance calls
him a [ __ ] colonizer i'm a white dude
i look like this guy i sound like him a
little bit i wear hats like him but i
don't get mad when lance calls white
people colonizers i does i i think he's
correct
actually but i don't get pissed off i
don't get offended and the reason why is
because that's i i don't think he's
talking to me right and i don't think
lance is really talking to me
because i i don't i don't feel or see it
that way but this is a mindset of a call
right but this guy gets really [ __ ]
pissed off right and i think that's
where it probably started and again i
didn't go back and do my own research
but i could just tell by the way that
this guy talks by his body language by
the the words that he uses um and i can
and that what he said about you
uh
very casually here i mean in that video
right he oh like whether he has a friend
or not i don't know that's off in the
corner you know he's got his tv going
and he's like
uh and he goes you know that that danish
guy
uh
you know feather not dot or whatever and
my friends tell me that's racist and
he's he's just openly and alive because
he's looking because he's looking off
now of course we'll probably he's
looking at a friend whether the friend
is real i don't know
if karen tizzy modern warrior or that
other
i think it's like the different kind of
indian guy and i know you're gonna say
that that's racist but it's just a
[ __ ] statement um
because there's some other guy
that's like dots not feathers and um
he's
my friend is shaking his head he thinks
i'm being racist right now well hey
i gotta say before there was a video he
made not that long before where he on
his page where he said i'm here at a
friend's house and my friends who know
me are the ones who can tell you whether
or not i'm racist and he made it sound
like there's a lot of people there but
there was one person there and he said
uh hey am i raised and i'm not gonna put
you on film because i don't want you to
get talked to everyone but am i racist
no you're certainly not they call me
racist and then in this live at the same
exact house talking the same exact
person that he qualified as the person
would be able to tell you whether or not
he's racist he says um there's that
other guy dot not feather now my friends
look at me and saying that i'm racist he
thinks that i'm racist
that's the same guy wait yes the same
prince yes yes it's the same house the
same boy and i go you just
you just like destroyed your own
argument you just
like you proved it this time you did it
so so i grew up in a very racist part of
the country
i grew up around a lot of racist people
uh up until a certain age i i didn't
know this but i was
in fact a racist and what i mean by that
is i was taught racist things now i'm so
glad that i came to my [ __ ] senses
and realized human beings are human
beings and there's no [ __ ] cause for
anyone to look at someone that is of a
different religion a different skin
color a different nationality a
different culture whatever the [ __ ]
divides us up right that these
[ __ ] want to divide us up as
we're all [ __ ] human beings
absolutely
now
i will tell you that
a friend in racist ville
is not really the [ __ ] thing that you
go to like hey hey other white guy who
that we make inward jokes with each
other yes am i a racist like what the
[ __ ] number one that's not really a very
good qualifier and when you're having
this is the same thing as when you're
like well i got a black friend i got a
friend i'm not racist i got a black this
is the same thing when you go to your
friend like hey am i a racist like if
you have to ask someone if you have to
go right like intentionally ask someone
am i a race you're a [ __ ] racist yeah
that's what you are especially if the
guy is saying hey you're being racist
yeah right right
that's even worse right but but the a
simple act the simple act of a white
person especially a white person
asking someone that they know and knows
them
am i a racist that that you are just by
saying that i mean i actually i have i
have heard this
phrase before
is that
out of someone's mouth a white is an old
dude white person's mouth he said i'm
not a racist i just hate black people
i'm like well
what i'm like wait a sec what is your
definition of racism right right have
you have you picked up a dictionary
before and like read the word that
you're saying i don't think you
i don't think you but but this is but
again you have to remember is that
in in in this guy's world in his world
racism
is much more intense than just
you know casually making jokes about
someone or asking their other white
friend if they're racist right they they
have they have no [ __ ] clue and it's
because they are inherently racist
they've been taught it they've been
indoctrinated into it and they they want
it to stay that way that's what the
whole crt and all that [ __ ] is they want
it to stay that way that they can just
i'm not i'm
oh i'm not a racist i have a black
friend i'm i'm not a racist am i bill am
i a racist right this is what by the way
putting putting someone on the spotlight
whether they're on camera or not like
that person is going to be like uh
maybe maybe they think it but they also
might be like oh
racist might be a little too much
because of okay you know it's more
casual here it's right we're just
getting our toes in right we're we're
having beers together i don't know right
you know yeah let's joke about yeah uh
but you know in that moment the friend
also might be like uh
no no you're not racist right right and
then later obviously in a more
casual conversation setting where you
know whatever's happening and then he
just says it he's like okay that
that's kind of racist you know it's uh
the whole fact of just like putting
someone in the spotlight
i don't know if your friend is going to
openly say
yeah you're you're a racist you know
i i have had to tell some of my friends
like i've had to check some people
before like oh yeah like you go to a
party and you're standing around and
you're in you're you know you're talking
and all of a sudden
uh and it's normally it's normally
they're they're bringing up black people
right
and or or mexicans
those are the two really easy targets
in in white rural america those are the
two really easy targets another one is
muslims um those are the those are the
easy targets right uh and and it's
obvious why they're easy targets is
because they have all these tropes about
them um you know and it's not it's not
that
for one instance i had to have an
argument with someone
that that black people can swim
this this was the thing that we were
doing
like i'm like you you you have got to be
[ __ ] kidding me this is not and of
course you know
obviously i had to check them
but
to to be quite honest with you it
doesn't help because they really don't
believe this stuff
like they don't really believe it it's
again it's their comfort blanket to make
them feel like they're not ra the things
that they believe and the things that
it's the crt [ __ ] that that [ __ ] crt
voodoo right right that they've been
told to be afraid of
and but that like comes down to like
someone like zach he doesn't ultimately
understand the reason why he doesn't
like it when he when people say he's a
racist
is because he truly believes he's not
he believes we're just because these are
just words they don't affect you i could
say whatever i want and what he doesn't
understand it's something that i've
tried to explain not to him but uh to
other people
to other people is that what you don't
understand is how
these little like jokes even behind my
back even to like your friends that no
you're not racist how harmful and
violent these little jokes can be right
you don't get is that you could let's
say he got my race correct and was uh
making fun of me and saying that i was a
terrorist he didn't do that but let's
say that was his emma um the thing is if
him and his friends are joking about
that in private and i never even hear it
you never even hear it they just do it
in private
and one day there was like a bombing
it is more likely that they are going to
believe that it was someone middle
eastern who did that or if there's
somebody at like a uh
say they're at a mall or something and
someone's got a gun like a an assault
rifle rifle or something and is going to
start killing people they're more likely
to believe it is a middle eastern person
and more likely to put that on someone
like me
because they've not while they think
it's a joke they have normalized this
between them they have normalized in
their own minds so they've developed
associations with certain groups
and they think these are just jokes get
over it don't be so sensitive i'm like
but it's not the jokes right now that
i'm worried about it's what you're
planting in your brain it's the seeds
that you're planting so that like you
start believing so that when like
like let's be really clear when there is
a a white shooter
right
regardless of what's happening there's
no laws that are made nothing changes
nothing nothing really happens we we
have this gun argument back and forth
and then it's over but if what if it
just so happens that the person is let's
say an illegal immigrant is their words
um but if it's an undocumented uh an
undocumented immigrant um or let's say
it's a middle eastern person or a black
person or something like that they will
grab that and run they will go oh we
need we need better immigration laws we
need i told you guys i told you
shouldn't be letting them in there
and then and then there are laws made as
a result there are things that change
you have people putting on like camo
grabbing their guns and going to the
border and going like we're going to
guard the border now we're an amateur
it's just confirmation bias is what it
is they've been waiting
for these you know they get these little
hints that
this group is associated with this thing
right and as soon as they get one
fraction of that
to be true then they go like you said
told you [ __ ] told you dude it's
right here goes the [ __ ] suburbs
right
well but then it can happen then it can
happen on the opposite side where they
pass a law in florida where you can mow
down a bunch of protesters with the
vehicle and then
a guy in wisconsin who's not on their
side you know they you know oh look he's
a he's a bite whatever the hell they
said but he gets in a car and he he
drives through a parade and he kills
several people injuring dozens and then
all of a sudden that law in florida and
you know they don't want to talk about
that law in florida anymore you know
right like it was the same thing with
the
the the new black panther party showed
up
with assault style rifles which i did
not agree with i was like you you should
not be making display like that now
obviously the display was to send a
message um but it's the same display as
when white people do it it it's the same
display but
even even for the black panther for
instance it's like
that wasn't an issue in california like
it wasn't a ban i think it was
government buildings but it was put in
place by reagan right and it's like well
why do you think it wasn't until
this group of people
of a certain color
showed up to
show so do you think do you think you
could do like a like like a reverse
psychology like i thought that biden
could do reverse psychology on these
people he could be like you know what i
was completely wrong about the vaccine
it has a chip in it
and and like all this [ __ ] honestly
and they would be like let's go get it
and then
at this point like we could get the
other 25 percent done it would be over
with we're we're done with coronary
arteries honestly that that would i
really think that would work
um do you think that's that [ __ ]
stupid yes
yeah
yes final answer yes yes i do i do yeah
we're not playing trivia yet but it's
very it gets very tribal it's it's so
insane and the expectation that we are
going to be as tribal too
um is also like mind-boggling where they
go like oh uh you didn't like something
bite and did i bet you regret your vote
i'm like
dude i hate trump like i don't like i
may not like about it i hated trump do
you understand that like i'm able to
criticize i mean he kind of puts you in
danger on a daily basis
right yes he literally he literally
banned my family from the country he
literally did like a muslim bin oh it's
not called a muslim ban well he
he literally said let's find a way to do
it let's go brandon see that's the same
[ __ ] so so back to the misfit patriot
because
on something that you touched on
as you said he was saying that words
don't matter and all this [ __ ] and
they're just words quit being such a
[ __ ] yeah really and and i hope he
[ __ ] watches this because coming from
a white guy with a [ __ ] beard and
wearing a hat you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
here's the thing you got so pissed off
because
because an indigenous person called you
a [ __ ] colonizer that's right your
[ __ ] ass went on tick tock and thought
it was a good [ __ ] idea to [ __ ] with
a bunch of good
uh
creators that have a big following and
you and you [ __ ] [ __ ] around and
found out so if words don't matter quit
being such a punk-ass [ __ ] and take
your colonizer and and [ __ ] deal with
it you pieces of [ __ ] exactly and and
and to add to that he wanted to evict me
because i called him the word racist he
wanted to try to get me
he posted my uh my landlord's phone
number online
followers to call him so he's mad that
you're doxing him but then he's doxing
you if i want to like confirm or verify
something that i find sometimes i'll
just
yeah
i will say i mean like social
engineering is a an impressive tool
uh uh yeah it it it involves no hacking
at all so so wait wait wait wait a
second wait a second social engineering
you're talking about like with the
january 6 where they just start the fbi
just started posting pictures and videos
and everyone on the internet just like
we're going to find out who the [ __ ]
these people are no no it's more
manipulation uh is what it is it's um
but it's a form of gathering information
that is um that involves uh basically um
engineering the way uh we all work like
you think about how we interact how we
what we post what we do and to try to
just manipulate that a little bit which
could be
what you're saying yeah like for
instance like for for one example for me
like i used to take photos in places i
was not supposed to be right on tops of
roofs or in different areas or whatever
in different cities
and wait wait wait let me write let me
write these places down i'm not going to
tell you where it was
you know there are photos in different
cities
do not do your magic on these
different buildings you know and things
like that but like an example of social
engineering would be i would go to a
hotel right and i would get in the
elevator and i would say something like
oh no like oh where's
oh no my my mom has the
the key card right to get on the
elevator to go up to a certain level i'm
like oh shoot and i'd be in the elevator
with someone else i'm like i'm so sorry
like
my mom's out and about she has the key
card would you be able to like like help
me get up the floor and like oh yeah no
problem you know whatever boom scan like
it's moments like that where you're able
to manipulate the situation so that you
can benefit from it you know obviously
hopefully not in a super illegal way but
yeah yeah yeah you want to do it i don't
want to commit any crimes
hey and i've been doing that since i was
really young i remember being like a
little kid going to disneyland and doing
this trick where i just go through the
line and go mom mom mom mom mom where
are you mom excuse me mom mom might get
to the front get on the ride or i do
that i do that you just get right
there was this one uh pedo that we found
um it was actually a username jolly no
this is not the pedo there was a
username jolly good ginger that was
being harassed by an account it that
said montana and it had a birth date
that uh right after it a full birthday
to me it seemed like it was a minor
but the way they were attacking uh jolly
ginger and commenting it didn't it
seemed like an adult so he's like can
you help me with this and i'm like it
but the screen looks like it might be a
kid and he's like i think it might be a
fake screen name like well why would
they pretend to be a kid unless they're
unless they're a pedo and so
and so we looked at it
first thing i did was
[Music]
and from there i needed to verify it
because the way that i found it isn't
enough and so this was social
engineering i messaged him
and i said lee dude what's up what's
going on uh why aren't you answering my
calls
and he says
um
it's something to that effect and he
says uh
who lee i'm like yeah that's you and he
goes yeah i know i'm like league this is
lee green right he's like yeah i'm like
yeah dude why can't i get a hold of you
and then he video calls me as soon as he
video calls me i obviously point the
phone away screenshot his face um say
[ __ ] you block him go uh run your facial
recognition and then it pulls up
it pulls up virginia um
uh what is it uh sex offender registry
list
and the name lee green
and i go
name verified and also oh my god and uh
the thing that he went to prison for was
um
communicating online communication with
and then i went through his friend's
following list found all the miners and
went ahead and uh
i i told jolly ginger how to report that
and i went ahead and sent it into it so
so let's talk about this real quick
before we before we play trivia because
this just brought up something in my
mind and and um i think we were getting
at it earlier is
when it goes from like this misfit
patriot just being a dumb [ __ ]
because let's face it he was just being
a dumb [ __ ] and he continues to be a
dumb [ __ ] and all you have to do all you
have to do is just put the phone down
but there are sometimes
there are some times when some of these
activities actually cross a line
and they cross a line into criminality
right yeah like sometimes you're just
being a dumb [ __ ] and then
you get found out and your work finds
out you're a dumb [ __ ] and they might
terminate zach committed a crime i mean
zach committed many crimes but there's
one he committed against me that he
might even if i take no action he may
actually be he may actually end up in a
lot of trouble
uh that is
that that is
uh i i'd like i said i have tons of
lawyers in my um in my dms they
constantly are like hey you can do this
you can't do this i'll check can i say
this you can't say this and so now they
they're like my whole dm thing lit up
going like uh i'm sending this to san
antonio or whatever
like i didn't do this i have nothing to
do with this i just wanted to you know i
was just making peace with zach and
getting out of it but he may actually be
like lit in legal trouble because of
that action and so this isn't anything
like you're charging him or are trying
to i don't just it's just he's committed
a crime and he's committed if law
enforcement decides to charge him then
that's correct and so you got a bunch of
lawyers that hate his guts because of
everything he's said that are now like
try send that in and and the thing is is
they're probably going to look more into
it and see how he's doing that with
literally everyone else too he like
these are all the things that he's doing
he thinks he thinks this is a play from
our this is just another thing from your
playbook playbook i don't do this zack i
told him in texas i just deck i don't do
this and he goes you think you're the
hero this is exactly what you do i'm
like no it's not zach
i don't do this and any you won't hear
any different
and um and so
yeah i may have a
temporary
uh you know truce with him
but that was a crime the way it led to
that was a crime so when it crosses over
to this crime thing
because that's a sticky area right i
mean now now if you if you've discovered
a crime now it's like well what what do
i
what do i do you know like some of these
attorneys are you know like you're
saying in your dm's they're they're
going oh my god this is a crime you know
now there's a different line drawn yeah
well you it depends it depends where you
have to submit it to and again that's
where i try to get like lawyers advice
would i send this to how do i do this
one um but there are a lot of uh there
are a lot of things that move slowly
especially if you're depending on the
government to do it
so
for example i won't say who this is
because this is one of this is one of
the ones that i
i have to wait like literally probably
years for this to take effect
um but there's somebody who i'm is
probably
out of everyone that i've gone up
against probably in the most trouble out
of every every single person and it's
not because something he did to me it's
because i dug into him and i found his
i i found that the business
that this person
is um
is uh
basically
using the business that they
allegedly own
um has this business has been expired
the license is excited for years and
they have been claiming it on their tax
forms
they have been accepting charity for it
and um and uh
one other thing oh uh
they're they're committing tax they're
recommending tax fraud charity fraud and
um
i can't remember the third one uh but
they're operating with a license but two
of those are federal crimes
and so i sent that to the irs and the
prosecuting attorney in a current legal
battle that he is in that i can't say
against who but a high profile
person that is suing him right now too
um to just bury this person but they
told me um
when you're going through the irs and
stuff this could take years to actually
oh yeah yeah sure so like i can't make a
video going like got him just just hang
on right i'm gonna have to just wait
until it finally happens
thank you for coming on but but before
we go
we always like to play a trivia game
okay
[Music]
thank you for coming on but but before
we go
uh we always like to play a trivia game
okay
welcome to trivia internet edition today
we're going to ask questions about the
internet here are the rules
the rules i'm going to ask five
questions each question is worth one
point
the first one to ring in on their buzzer
will get a chance to answer the question
get it wrong and your opponent will have
a shot for that point whoever has the
most points after the five questions
wins are you ready yes let's do it let's
play
question
number one
on trivia internet edition
question one
what year was the internet invented was
it eight
oh are you giving options yeah well on
this one i am oh okay
gabe was the first one to ring it let me
let me read let me read the uh
let me read the multiple choice you
gotta say there's multiple choices some
of these are multiple choices some of
them are not i will i will indicate
before okay from now on i will make sure
to clarify
a
1972
is it b
2008
is it c
1954 or is it d 1969 uh it was 1974
1972
2008
1954
or 1969. oh man that 2008 sounds real
good right now
i'm gonna say 1969. that is correct that
is correct nice question number two an
internet trivia
question this is a multiple choice
question
this is multiple choice so hang on with
the buzzers unless you hear it and you
want to buzz in
who invented
the hashtag
was it a jack dorsey was it b elon musk
was it c chris messina or was it d al
gore
i've got no idea
i'm going to go ahead and say it's c
that is correct chris messina is correct
so what happened was now i i i've read
this before and i've read this about
chris messina and i went and looked him
up
uh he is like a blogger and he wanted a
way to like ties all his things together
and all his conversations together so he
made this little tag that they could all
search it was searchable right
and um some people thought he should
like
sell it or something and i don't know
make a video you can go research it go
do your own research wait his name is
carlos mencia you said no no
it sounds like carlos carlos mencia is a
completely different person but it won't
be funny it would be cool if carlos
mencia
christmas it's
m-e-s-s-i-n-a i might be saying it
completely wrong
but it's chris messina christina
yes question number three
question number three
multiple choice question right
what
is the most visited website in the world
sorry sorry is it a
is it a pornhub
is it b facebook
is it c google or is it d
youtube
pornhub google a a pornhub
facebook see google d youtube of all
time
most visited website in the world
[Laughter]
i feel like the world how many how many
of these websites were you on today gabe
first off well pornhub is my home page
so that's right right like when you put
when you push in google chrome
all i want to say is like alex jones i
plead the fifth i'm not going to tell
you
okay so oh man i feel like the wording
of this question is tricky and will lead
to the wrong answer
okay well you know these are you know me
with questions and the trivia questions
no i know it's just like there's no
metrics so i don't or there's no link
the the most visited website in the
world
i want us
[Music]
okay i'll say google you are correct it
is c google see i was like i wasn't i
was pronounced even on on the list
really really
no i well it wasn't in like the top five
i think
in the world see that's the key is the
world um but but pornhub uh it does
appear as somewhere on the list but but
i just threw that one in there
especially on they just you know just to
toss it up i mean you know the hub's
good right that's all there's all right
people say i mean i mean i i wanted the
audience to get excited you know
they are now because well josh hawley
apparently this is going to be the
number one issue of all time i mean this
is going to be what we're talking about
is porn we didn't talk about this in the
80s and 90s enough so now we're going to
rehash the whole porn thing duel it out
in the hub that's right well and we we
are not tired of evangelicals [ __ ]
so we want more of their [ __ ] about
porn and video games perfect idea this
is totally gonna work for these
conservatives i'm sure of it
okay
about as much as i'm sure that josh
hawley's
uh entire history isn't pornhub um okay
question
question number four
what does
www
stand worldwide
danish you got it worldwide okay i was
going to say world wrestling better but
no no no no
www i knew that's why
www.whatever.com right yeah yeah right
world wide web that is so we have a
bonus question on this
okay so uh to you first donish and if
you get it wrong then gabe has a chance
bonus question on the www question
bonus question is what does html stand
for
uh
hot thick moms in your area
no no you're still stuck on the pornhub
question
this is not a bonus on the pornhub
question this is a bonus on the w uh
was it like hyperlink uh
html what is it technical mumbo jumbo uh
uh
landing i don't know i really wish that
was the actual
technical
technical
jumbo like actually that's actually kind
of what it seems like to like html is to
me i'm like yeah this is all technical
so
mumbo
i wish that was but that is incorrect so
we're going to throw at the gate to see
if he can get gain the point gabe what
does
for the bonus point what does html stand
for
hyper text markup language
correct correct
yours was yours was way better your
answer the
the technical mumbo jumbo actually
i'm gonna i'm gonna go to i'm gonna go
to the internet and i'm going to put a
request in
the official name to that do we have to
like unplug something at home office on
the internet to uh yeah i think if we
just like reset the modem and right
right control panel we can we can reset
it to where it's now technical mumbo
jumbo non-text markup okay yeah
good good okay we should do that after
the show okay final question
question number five
can we clear these buzzers question
number five final question
what was the name
of the ibm computer system that won over
5 million dollars
on jeopardy
watson
watson is correct
he was the first ib and i didn't i
actually didn't know that he won five
million bucks apparently watson was on
several different episodes do you
remember this
i remember i remember him being on i
don't remember how much he won
or it i guess
well whatever it is
do you remember this danish when when
watson uh went and won jeopardy um i i
thought you were talking about a guy
named watson who had ibs i i missed the
best
no no so it so so ibm created a computer
yeah and i don't know if it was
specifically created to play jeopardy or
not but um it's like deep luba for
jeopardy kind of yeah i think so
but but this computer played two other
conditions and i believe they were
previous winners like they were some of
the you know the highest rated winners
or some [ __ ] probably the the jennings
guy right
yeah
[Laughter]
what is ken jones
what is a ken jennings um no it's so
they built this computer to play to play
on jeopardy or or they had this ibm
computer and they programmed it to play
on jeopardy um but it actually it was ai
so it's not like
like google where it knows the answers
it is actually you know and i'm not sure
of how they made it learn or what but i
remember this being in the news and i'm
like oh my god we are completely [ __ ]
we are so [ __ ] this is this is the end
of it all
this was the origin of terminator right
well yeah when it when when the
terminator starts winning five million
dollars on jeopardy we are all
completely [ __ ] as if this thing could
not just hack into someone else's system
and then right give me the five million
i mean here here average americans are
trying to fight for 15 an hour and this
[ __ ] goes on jeopardy wins five
million bucks
doesn't even have a heart and it can't
even use it
yeah wow what the [ __ ] this is
ridiculous
but congratulations to watson for being
here
oh yeah let's let's tally up let's tally
up so we got for gabe is that one is
that the cash prize three four no no oh
cash price what the f this isn't [ __ ]
jeb bitcoin
yeah i'll i'll se i'll send you tony
coin
oh yeah
it's a new it's a new [ __ ] one of
them you know fancy [ __ ] dollar bills
or whatever the hell they're called i
don't know i don't do the crypto [ __ ]
okay so it's called by the way crypto
yeah yeah crypto crypto currency i i
don't i don't do it go ahead i don't i
don't i don't know that doesn't that
does make me think though of crypto
currency
and now i'm curious about this whole
currency but only for cairns
that oh i think like uh
people who call in and complain about
cryptocurrency
is cryptocurrency the actual the actual
bitcoin thing or is it the people who
call and pissed off which is it like
that's no it's a combination that's how
you make your cryptocurrency yeah you
have to call in the rule and you're
calling the mail
yeah call the manager's manager or call
the police on somebody in your parking
structure you got you got to build it up
have you ever tried to listen to someone
who's trying to tell you about
cryptocurrency i haven't even tried to
listen no oh my god
go ahead this is why i brought you both
here i want to start a project shut the
[ __ ] up
no we're not sharing no goddamn
presentation just because you won the
trivia does not mean you get to pitch us
on on crypto but i've had i've had
someone they didn't really pitch me they
were like no i want to pay you encrypt
i'm like pay me with what they're like
no [ __ ] i'm like no no they're like no
i'm like bitcoin they're like no it's
not really bitcoin it's like a new one
i'm like oh
okay yeah that's exactly what i want
some worthless
[ __ ] internet tokens or some [ __ ]
like
like i would just pay me in the chucky
cheese tokens at least i can go play
some [ __ ] games of chucky geez i
don't do tokens anymore
call digital they have their own
cryptocurrency oh wow what the hell
[ __ ] chardonnay yeah
it's really it's really cool now because
what they do not that i'm you know
you're promoting but um
they they have you could buy time so
like you can play any games you want for
a certain amount of time so this is kind
of like dave and buster's because i've
been today and they give you the car to
dave and busters and of course you know
there you buy the food and the beer and
you know the the whole nine yards yeah
but david buster's you don't have a
whole musical band of animals that's
true they actually don't have it don't
the one black white house does oh they
still haven't been one of my one of the
videos that i had viral i'm sorry go
viral on my page and that video got like
millions of views because people like
where are you how do you have one look
at look at danish going viral with with
the open signs during the pandemic and
the chuck e cheese animatronics
you know i think
it's quite an arc
right it's like a versatile tiktok
account you know it really should just
transform to look at this like i i could
just do a look at this account okay look
what i said look what i found people are
really into the things that i come
across just like i found a collection of
toenails on the street look at this look
at this
boom
right what's that so thanks for playing
internet trivia here on the tony
michaels podcast uh unfortunately donish
i have to inform you that that gabe did
win uh gabe had one two three four
points free
well um we will be doing an audit with
the cyber ninjas because it was the
internet trivia later on in the year and
then probably next year we'll do another
audit then as well uh we'll count it at
least 14 times i'm probably going to say
that you are probably still a loser we
might go to the supreme court it might
not it depends on if a pedal guy gets
involved or not so i really do
appreciate you playing
trivia internet edition
[Music]
all right so that was fun thanks for
coming on the show let's one more time
uh before you get off here tell us one
more time where we can find you uh your
link tree all that kind of stuff where
you want us to go to find all your your
content so i am that danish guy and that
that danish guy on tick tock that's
where you see me most i'm also that
danish guy on instagram on twitter you
could also find me as that danish guy
and sure enough go on youtube type in
that danish guy you'll see me there too
um if you want to go to cash app do not
type that donna skye that's not me uh
you want to type in the only honest you
know and just empty
your bank your bank account right there
that's right uh just you could put
crypto i don't care crypto you want the
tony coin the bitcoin i don't care
shove it in there yeah if watson is
listening drop that five mil bro
that's fantastic thanks for joining us
thanks for joining us
find us on twitter at tony michael's pod
and at the tony michaels or be lame and
don't [ __ ] boneheads
we'll be back in 60
seconds i've always wanted to learn a
new language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble
maggot edition makes it really easy to
learn and there's lots of lessons to
choose from like subtly racist to
full-blown white supremacist the first
lesson began with learning simple
phrases and soon i was putting those
words and phrases into a conversation
each lesson takes about 10 to 15 minutes
to complete and they're all really
different which keeps things interesting
the app is really smart it actually
keeps track of the word that i'm
struggling with i chose babble mag
edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now i can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new maga skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back
i want to thank
that danish guy for coming on the show
today we really do appreciate having him
i think we have some updated news
that's going on over on the the tweety
tweets
uh we have this new term of service type
thing that's going on uh gabe can you uh
can you inform us a little bit i i think
i got this let me pull it up here
basically twitter has implemented a new
policy that would allow people to flag
private media and private media could be
photos or videos that you could then say
you know i didn't consent to being put
online so basically what
uh
danish and others are doing to hold
people accountable and bring them to the
forefront of
the public you know whether it's
um
making them known for the
the terrible things they do what have
you
now twitter
um and then is is is
taking it to the effective they will now
uh ban you from suspend you block you
from twitter
um if you're violating these guidelines
so
uh for anyone who is
watching following that type of like
accountability like content
um just know that
this new policy is um
is 100 real and serious i mean i think
danish right now is
uh
locked out of his account even today
already yeah yeah
because
this went into effect yesterday i
believe yeah basically jack dorsey was
like peace
and then uh they implemented this new
policy and then that was it and so um
i'm sure there are other people that
that this is happening to but it will
definitely be one where
white supremacist racist karen's whoever
uh
can now
report and complain
the people that are being outed
exactly so so there's good because i'm
reading this uh this policy and let me
bring it back up here again i'm reading
this policy as there's good and bad to
this um now exactly how twitter enforces
this
i believe that's where it's going to go
into the good and bad side right like
how good is it how bad is it because
there is actual bullying that happens
right like like it's unwarranted like
someone yeah do something to trigger
and there's there's this this this
barrage of
uh maybe someone you know gets in a tiff
with someone in a reply section that's
and and then uh a following comes in and
harasses them and bullies them and then
someone starts to post you know what
information they may find like donish
said uh he never posts someone's address
um you know he never does that because
he wants no malice towards someone so i
i um i hope that twitter you know at
first it's going to be uh very hairy i'm
sure on how they enforce this new policy
um but i'm hoping more good comes than
bad of this because i definitely do not
want because i think it's newsworthy a
lot of times when someone in a public
place uh we've seen these videos like in
an airport or starbucks or a subway shop
someone's causing a scene or doing
something um let's hope that
that that that those people can still be
held accountable for some of that that
craziness uh but this new twitter policy
does put into question some of the
content that donish and people like
donish might make yeah
yeah and unfortunately um
you know like he said i mean i i think
he even said in the interview or maybe
in the extended interview he'll he talks
about how
regardless of
the outcome of these policies
they will find other avenues they will
find other platforms they will share it
you know right in other places because
you know just because they're being
silenced somewhere
whether it's justified or not you know
there is enough there is an alternative
place that they can get to and to be
clear this is just twitter's policy so
far yeah yeah yeah just twitter's policy
i mean obviously case-by-case basis on
other platforms but no one has a private
media policy like twitter does right now
and i don't know if that's because
you know they they've been seeing more
of this type of content and they needed
to rein it in um but unfortunately right
now you know people that are on the good
side who are bringing attention to
not bad bad people bad right
uh are the ones who are you know getting
the blunt end of the stick here right
right well and again i think it's on how
twitter's going to enforce this thing so
you know if they're if they're enforcing
it to where uh
you know maybe it's where someone who's
taking information that's not uh
currently on other social media
platforms um and they're publishing it
maybe that's how they do it you know i
don't know how they police this thing
yeah make it more good than bad but
we'll see how that goes so also also i
don't i don't want everyone forget go
vote for bone end of the week we got don
jr chris cuomo and
lauren beaubert this week go vote and
then this weekend sometime we will post
hopefully on sunday night we will post
our quick episode to explain who wins
who wins bonehead of the week
and uh also go follow while you're there
because it's on the twitter account the
podcast at tonymichaelspod uh on twitter
that's where the poll is so go go do
that and you can go to the bonehead of
the week and you can actually recommend
boneheads for us to put on the list
so go do that as well if you like the
bone of the week thanks for joining us
here thank you again uh donna shout out
again for him recording that episode uh
i like the censored parts that was um
yeah there was some stuff that he told
us we're like yeah we should be careful
about what we're putting in interviews
and because it's this is airing on
twitter with this new policy and that
sort of thing so yeah so um again we
want to thank thank donish again uh for
coming on the show and don't remember
tomorrow thursday friday we have we have
the [ __ ] list roundup
noon eastern 11 central and the next
week as always wednesday three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern right here
same time same place youtube twitter
twitch and then and before we go
is there something you'd like to say
gabe before we go
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking